Before we can begin to use our water tools, we need to enable the plugin inside of our
project and restart the editor.
Now to do this, all you need to do is simply go up to the plugins menu, look for the water
section and then enable water.
You can enable buoyancy water actors and water advanced to see more examples of how to utilize
different features of the water tools.
Let's just pop over to the editor and look at this now.
So from our editor, we'll come up to our edit plugins and then from our plugins menu,
we will scroll all the way down here to the bottom and look for water.
Once we've located the water, we simply enable the plugins that we want and we'll see a
little restart editor pop up down here or in the lower right hand corner of the editor.
Once we have restarted the editor, we can go up to the quickly add, type in water and we
should see something like the following which is going to show us all of the water tools
we have available.
Let's go ahead and check that now in the editor.
With the editor open, we go up to our quickly add, type in the word water and then we should
see the water body ocean, lake river, shallow water and all of the other parts of the plugin
that are available to us.
Once we have established that all of this is enabled and working, we are ready to move
on to the next part which will involve setting up our world so that we can use these tools
in any way, shape or form we wish.